Tiger Woods has been accused of sexism
after handing a rival a tampon during a
competition now we're seeing giving
Justin Thomas the tampon after hitting
the ball further than he did during the
first round of the Genesis Invitational
in California the pair who were friends
who are seen laughing and embracing
after the incident or Skies either
Bennett can bring us up to date with
developments it's a pretty bizarre
episode this um that has clearly
backfired on Tiger Woods it was
supposedly a prank between friends but
now Woods the 15-time golf major
Champion is accused of sexism and
portraying women as inferior it happened
at a tournament in California as the
pair were walking off the T here's
Justin Thomas driving off the ninth tee
and in the footage afterwards you can
see that their hands come together here
it's quite hard to see in the in the
when it's played at normal speed but
when it's slowed down and this still
image reveals that something changes
hands and that item is a tampon why a
tampon well it's being interpreted as
wood saying to Thomas that he's playing
like a woman because he out drove him
off the tee hit the ball further
um and then the pair walk off laughing
and embracing not everyone is laughing
though clearly um after this pretty
blatant Texas exhibition of male
chauvinism that was clearly planned by
Woods as well he would have been walking
around half the golf course with this
tampon in his pocket waiting for the
opportunity to hand it to Thomas neither
the players were asked about this in
their post-round interviews but they
almost certainly will be now after their
second rounds which are now underway and
this tournament by the way is is the
latest comeback for Woods his first
competitive event since July the focus
was supposed to be on his playing his
golf but now that is clearly not the
case with his behavior overshadowing his
golf